mike tyson is going to return to fight
roy jones jr in an exhibition i still
don't know the difference between an
exhibition and a real boxing match they
still punch in both settings but tyson
will be back he's 54 years old and that
inspired today's draft nfl player who is
currently retired that we would like to
see
one more time and we explored the
possibility of like all time bring a guy
back from his prime and put him into
today's game but no this is a guy out
there right now who currently isn't
playing who currently is retired that we
want to see suit up and go right now 20
20. uh this is gonna be this is gonna be
a fun one i've got a trivia question for
you shireen get ready to stare blankly
into the camera as you try as you try in
vain to come up with the answer you
should be able to get this one though
i'm going to add to the pressure this is
more pressure than a first pitch this is
incredible pressure here we go
what nfl player shared the iron mic
nickname with mike tyson
well i think there were actually
two right iron mike webster and iron
mike singletary
see i was thinking iron mike did both of
them iron mike iron microwave
okay
i think iron mike ditka yeah they're
they're all iron mics i guess the the
answer key for this specific test is
webster
i agree with you though there are
multiple iron mics that are out there i
think of iron mike ditka i would have
said ditka and i'd have been upset i'd
have called for a recount and and
additional research and uh
an arbitration to ultimately resolve it
but we'll give you that one you got it
right and uh you get the first pick in
the draft of the guys currently retired
we would like to see back in the nfl
right now
well i think you have to start with
andrew luck who surprisingly retired
before the start of last season he's
only 30 just turned 30 and
we think he's fully capable of
continuing to play in the nfl and it's
not going to surprise me if he does come
back and play at some point in the nfl
it's obviously not going to be this
season but maybe he gets that itch again
and and comes back or maybe he's retired
for good i don't know but he's awfully
young and has a lot of talent and time
that he could do it if he wanted to do
it we know the injuries just got to him
mentally physically and he just didn't
feel like he could do it anymore but
maybe at some point he feels like he can
come back and do that but he seems like
the obvious choice in this
well andrew luck would have been my
first choice in a draft of players we
want to see unretire and stay but if we
want him to come back for one game i
don't really care about andrew luck for
one game i'd love to see him come back
and continue his career but he is only
30. there's no intrigue there we know he
can come back and do it for one game i
want somebody that at least is going to
bring to the table that question of
can you still do it given the amount of
time that you've been off that's why for
me the first choice the obvious first
choice was calvin johnson he's still
only 34 right he's younger than larry
fitzgerald he entered the league
multiple years after i think four years
after larry fitzgerald did calvin
johnson enter the league and he left
because of that accumulation of injuries
much like andrew luck for one game
i want to see what a healthy and rested
calvin johnson could do for any team how
do you game plan against the calvin
johnson when you really don't know is he
still megatron do you put two guys on
him until you get the idea that he can't
move like he used to i'd be fascinated
by calvin johnson in a one game return
whether it's with the lions or anyone
else what can calvin johnson do four
years after he retired but still only 34
years old
yeah he was my next pick mike in 2015
was his last season and he had over 1200
yards and surprisingly
retired but i'd like to see him because
he could be the first player to be in
the profitable hall of fame to return
and play another game in the nfl
something that joe gibbs did as a coach
but he's eligible for the hall of fame
this year and i i would assume that he
would get into the hall of fame this
season this year uh we'll see how that
works out but wouldn't you love to see
him come back as a hall of fame player
and play in the nfl at a young age see
hey uh that shireen you're the one who
has the vote i'm just the one who can
snipe from the weeds i wouldn't put him
i definitely wouldn't put him in the
first time no no no one yeah
i would not put him in on first ballot
no way i don't know that he ever gets in
because he lacks the longevity he chose
to walk away before compiling the kind
of career statistics at a time when look
at how many guys at the top of the list
of the career statistics can't get in
now the question becomes does burning
very brightly for a short period of time
overcome that it's kind of the terrell
davis argument but no playoff wins in
his career and i know that we can't put
too much on one guy for that but i i
think it's a i think it's a much much
closer question and i don't think he
would get in the first time so uh that
may be any
yeah he may not because obviously
statistics are something that we don't
look at as much anymore for receivers
because the statistics are so so much
more than they used to be
did we shireen just froze up we froze
shireen froze she's forfeiting her
second pick in the draft we'll get her
back on here soon it was an uneventful
show until just then but calvin johnson
is a guy that i said at the moment he
retired i just look great dominant
player he holds the single season record
for receiving yardage and he was
unstoppable in his time but that window
was not an extended one and the question
becomes to put a guy in a hall of fame
how many years do you reasonably expect
when there are guys who played that
position for a lot of years and racked
up a lot of stats all right shereen's
back we move on to round two of the
draft of the players we would like to
see return for one game retired players
we want back for that one game shireen
who do you have
i'm going to take demarcus ware and he
actually tweeted yesterday hey would you
like to see me come back after mike
tyson
did his thing and he's only 38
turns 38 next week
still looks like he has the body he
works out awfully hard
owns a bunch of gyms around town and and
thinks he can still get after it so i'd
like to see demarcus ware come back for
one game and maybe sack andrew luck
since he was my first pick uh that'd be
that'd be a pretty good match up
see i knew you would go with a cowboy
but i'm stunned
i'm shocked i'm flabbergasted
at the cowboy you left on the board and
i'm taking him knocking i'm not giving
you a chance to redeem yourself on this
one
tony romo
we gotta see tony romo come back for one
game tony romo is still in that i mean
there's older quarterbacks than him drew
brees ben roethlisberger uh tom brady
still going strong get it together for
one game get a cortisone shot in your
back whatever you have to do get out
there and let's see what you can do for
one game i i i i almost made tony romo
my first pick uh but i'd love to see
what he can do for one game he almost
falls into that category of i'd love to
see him unretire for a full season and
see what he can do
mike tony romo is on my list of eight
players here but you know why i didn't
pick him he can't make it through a golf
tournament he's withdrawn from the last
two golf tournaments including including
this week so if you can't make it
through a golf tournament i don't think
you make it through one nfl game
that's a good point all right now i know
why you didn't pick him okay round three
who you got
all right this is probably not gonna
surprise you either uh since since uh he
is a texas a m maggie but i would love
to see
johnny manziel for one game with the new
orleans saints to see what sean payton
could do with him not necessarily a
quarterback but in a taysom hill type
role because i think johnny could be
great in that role have we ever had a
guy though uh that's played 14 career
games that gets as much publicity still
today years after his career has ended
that we still talk about him and we're
still talking about johnny manziel but i
would love to see him he and sean payton
have a relationship for one game to play
with sean payton just to use him in that
tyson hill type role because i think
he'd be great at it
i i
i
here's the thing though all these other
guys were talking about
i think there would be a team that would
say let's go
the problem with johnny manziel is
there's not going to be a team that says
let's go even sean payton isn't going to
say let's go i mean he's been out there
he's isn't that amazing when you think
about it i don't know what they talk
about behind the scenes when it comes to
johnny manziel but for him to have been
completely frozen out and never even
gotten a workout at the nfl level aren't
you shocked that when the door slammed
on him it slammed permanently
yeah he didn't do enough in his career
to make it worthwhile to even show the
potential and i think it was more behind
the scenes of what he didn't do it
wasn't you know it was not studying not
practicing doing all the things that he
did off the field i think it was all of
that that slammed the door shut but we
haven't seen that in many occasions mike
where a first round draft pick plays two
years 14 games and he's out of the
league and that happened with johnny
i got so many more that i can choose
from and my guiding light for this one
is putting myself in that mode of
sitting in front of the tv
during the game when the player would
return
how edge of the seat would i be right
that's what's causing one name to stand
out from the rest and it's troy polamalu
i want to see the long flowing hair
there may be some gray in it now i want
to see him out there he just seems like
the kind of guy who you know he was so
unconventional in his thinking and in
his training and it was all instincts
that drove him anyway i mean he was a
great athlete but it was his sense of
where the ball is going to be and when
it's going to be there and i think he
would have a good sense of how his body
currently would get him in position or
not to make a play but i would be edge
of the seat waiting and watching to see
what he would do next if he was back out
on the field so troy polamalu is my pick
that's a good choice you know another
one i thought about but i thought you
would call me on a technicality with the
rules i thought about a b because i
would love to see a b back on the field
and i'm not positive that a b is going
to get another chance antonio brown's
going to get another chance in the nfl
especially depending on what happens uh
with the economics here moving forward
what how the how the cap plays out but i
i do want to see ab play again because i
think he can continue to have a good
career and we start talking about hall
of fame stuff has he done enough already
to make the pro football hall of fame
with for all pros and everything else
that he's done i think he's getting
close but i do think he needs to
continue to play
well if the rules are the guy has to be
retired he would have been a great pick
on wednesday not a great pick on friday
because he
changed categories as we knew he would
uh all because look and we've talked
about this all week he's exasperated by
the fact that the nfl is stringing him
along that the nfl won't give him any
type of clarity on what his status is
he's essentially served a 14-game unpaid
suspension it's time to let him know
what his status is so he can get on with
his life and make his plans all right
bonus round uh my choice oh boy i got a
lot here i i i'm gonna go with a guy
that hmm boy
see i'm torn between terra loans and
randy moss
and
even though i think randy moss was
better than tara owens in their prime
i think i we had the video of t.o
running this week i think t.o is
probably in a better position to come
back and play right now and and it would
be such a spectacle to have tio on the
field and it would be such a build up
and it would be so entertaining i i got
to go terrell owens
yeah i would have picked terrell owens
too is a bonus pick because i i just
think he could still play i mean you see
his body not how how much he can play i
don't know it may be one of those things
when we're talking about limited snaps
but i do think he can make a catcher two
or three for you and create some
excitement uh on the football field and
randy moss is is a good consolation pick
in the bonus round too because i think
he's still got something left in him
him as well and uh i had luke keekley on
my list but as you said when you pointed
out on andrew luck
this guy can still play his recent
recently retired and he still could come
back and play there's no guarantee he's
going to continue to be retired so uh we
know what we have in luke kingly some of
these other guys for one game we're
talking about we want to see what they
can do in one game
i also had peyton manning joe thomas
chad johnson
brett favre brett favre i'd be
interested for one game and of course
tim tebow we gotta go get the tivo
mention in there especially because he
got the tie back to baseball and we have
we're gonna do a one round this is this
is the field of dreams baseball tie the
one player living or dead former player
that you could bring back in his prime
and put him on a football field today
who would it be
well you know i'm going to say roger
stallock there's no question about that
but
he would be the number one but but i
i would love to see i got to see roger
play many many times and he was my
favorite player growing up but a player
i never got to see who i would love to
see play would be otto graham or johnny
unitas either one just because i think
they're two of the greatest quarterbacks
in nfl history and i never got to see
either one of them play and would love
to see both of those guys play live
for me and and it pains me to say this
as a kid who grew up as a vikings fan
but
my all-time favorite player at any
position was and still is walter payton
and i'd want to see water i'd want to
see the the holding the ball out in one
hand with the kangaroo shoes and uh just
doing his thing especially to see how it
translated to today's nfl could could
today's defenders have a better chance
than the guys who flailed it air back in
the 70s against walter payton when he
was in his prime he was he was just
unstoppable and there was just something
about walter payton uh on the field off
the field that's the guy that definitely
absolutely i would go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports